deep in the forests of cambodia siem
reap province an ancient stone city
soars skyward
this is the sprawling complex of Angkor
Archaeological Park
[Music]
the site is located in the northwestern
region of the country and is only four
miles from the city of Siem Reap the
Khmer Empire serious capitals thrived
here from the 9th to 15th centuries over
an empire that stretched from Myanmar to
Vietnam including forested areas and
newly discovered suburbs Angkor covers
more than 400 square miles an area
considerably larger than New York City's
five boroughs and the massive Angkor Wat
is the most famed of all Cambodia's
temples it even appears on the nation's
flag the temples are architectural
masterpieces
laden with artistic treasures like the
bar relief galleries that tell enduring
tales of Cambodian history and legend
Angkor is as much about water as it is
about stone the site boasts an enormous
system of artificial canals dikes and
reservoirs these massive works
skillfully harnessed river and rainwater
to quench the thirst of some 750
thousand residents in the world's
largest pre-industrial city it's still a
mystery to scientists why the city's
rulers abandoned the site the town of
Siem Reap is the gateway to angkor and
is filled with lodging dining and tour
package options for all budgets the
airport in Siem Reap has service to the
capital and regular flights to nearby
countries those preferring to travel by
boat can also make the trip from pen on
pen in five or six hours about the same
time as by Road
peak tourist season and Angkor is
December and January when rainfall is
less likely and the climate is most kind
no matter the time of year a visit to
Angkor is sure to leave you awestruck
[Music]
[Music]